[Music]
sherry is with us sherry is in Kentucky
hi sherry welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show hi thank you so much for taking my
call
sure no question alright I have a thirst
I have a 32 year old daughter very
bright daughter we cleared through
college one and she got her degree we
are now putting her through the
barbering school and she's six months in
she still lives at home
never been married loved it at home we
started cutting the strings two years
ago and we told her she had two years to
get decided to go to school get through
school and get out on her own so
December 31st is her exit date good well
she thinks that we are kicking her out
and it will you know no matter what we
do we're not convincing her that we're
doing this for her own good so my
question is how do I let her know that
we love her and this is the best thing
she has an amazing boyfriend that he's
Christian he's asked her to marry him
once by our house he wants to start a
life with her they love each other but
she's not wanting to move so how do i
how do how do my husband I helped her
transition into her life whatever she
chooses to do for whatever reason she is
choosing to not hear you you've already
told her all of that yeah we told her
and we told her she has a favor money
we're not giving we don't we were given
their $100 a week for school get back
and forth with gap because she could
only work part-time we've quit that
we've cut that completely out we don't
give her any financial assistance at all
you are under you are under performing
as a 32 year old in our culture
dramatically underperforming which means
that we have done you harm by allowing
you to live here I'm so sorry we brought
you harm
I just love you too much to harm you
anymore you need to go be your own
person and have the dignity of hard work
and paying your own light bill and
buttering your own bread on both sides
but after it comes out of the toaster
this is ridiculous okay
how often should we ask her are you
putting she gets paid every week and how
often should we ask her hey are you
saving money hey are you doing what you
need to do or does she have you know if
she has any money no nun chose zero if
it would be for her boyfriend she
wouldn't have anything okay so here's
what I would tell her fans money like
crazy here's what I would tell you have
to move next week unless you agree to
save money out of every check and show
us that you're saving money your rent is
starting right now and your rent is that
you have to save money if you're not
willing to save money out of every check
you have to move next week I'll be
homeless I'll be on the street I know
you'll figure it out you'll figure it
out that's what our here yeah you'll
figure it out I know it's rough but
listen we've talked to you and talked to
you and talk to you okay and you're
acting like you're a 12 year old child
and it is time for you to grow up
exactly this is what it would sound like
at our house
yeah well it's going to sound like that
here too we put her through Financial
Peace University I bought the book
bought the audiobook she won't be
listened to it created a budget planner
for her but if she doesn't use it
there's nothing I could do she refuses
to participate in adulthood exactly and
gosh I don't know I'll just push her out
I would just say listen listen if you
you bring me your check on Friday and I
want to see the money set aside out of
your check into savings or you have to
leave on Friday I am I'm done I begged
you and begged you I've done stuff for
you we've paid for everything
this is over-the-top we're bringing you
harm we're buying your misbehavior we're
paying for your misbehavior for you to
continue to be an underperforming 32
year old I just love you too much to
participate in your crazy land okay I'm
not gonna participate in crazy anymore
this is not that's what my husband and I
think as well because I mean it's just
you know you guys are very sweet and
very kind and you've let it go on too
long yeah I agree we both agree we've
been trying to do the right thing yeah
you have you've set somewhere clear
boundaries with some real clear
timelines but she's still not still not
listening and god help this boy if he
marries her why is that she needs to go
out on her own and suffer just a little
bit before she's married material I mean
can you imagine trying to raise this
princess for the rest of her life
bless his heart I wouldn't want to yeah
I mean he's got she's not ready for
marriage she's not a viable adult yet
and so the end that none of this is you
being mean or mean being mean I'm being
a little bit smart aleck but it's just
to reinforce what the inner voice is
inside of you you've been saying these
exact same things to yourself and I'm
just trying to hit a reiterate with my
caustic 'no Sanat crazy why cuz she
makes us feel guilty that we're doing
something wrong and really we feel we're
doing something right you have done
something wrong you've waited too late
this should have been done four years
ago yeah well maybe like 10 years I love
it you're great you're fun well you know
what to do is just very very hard to do
with people you love who are misbehaving
whether it's parents whether it's
parents or brothers or sisters or kids
grown kids or whoever it is it's very
difficult when adults are misbehaving
and you can't make them do things the
only thing you can make someone do here
is not live into your house right and
just say you know what we've decided
that we made a mistake
December's not going to work for us you
have to leave by Friday if you don't
start saving money if you save money out
of
every check a substantial amount 50% of
every check starting immediately you can
stay as long as you prove to us that
you're doing that and you haven't spent
the money if you do not do that the
first week you do not do that you have
to move out I know I know her boyfriend
now her checks are direct deposited into
his savings account and he's putting
aside 200 off of every check so she is
saying honey right well that just
started like two weeks ago
okay well that that's a good sign what
does at least she'll have a little bit
of money to move out with it yes that's
what we're hoping that he should become
her not parent yeah yeah which yeah I
don't want that to happen he's trying
not to allow that to happen he's trying
to get her to come to him for advice
he's got a credit score in the high 800
I mean when it comes to financials you
know he's really good at it she just
doesn't yeah I never has been she just
doesn't produce she's so the bad news is
is that you know she's way
underdeveloped emotionally the good news
is she can catch up fast mm-hmm so a
little bit of a little bit being out
there and and I would tell him please
don't marry her until she has proven
herself to be an adult because I love
her too much for her to go through a
divorce and honestly her son she'll
drive you nuts
yeah god no no that's one question you
know that he says you know because
they're in the process of you know
getting a pre-approval for a home as
well who is but I don't think her her
and her boyfriend she doesn't have an
income oh she has a little bit of an
income yeah they don't need to buy a
house together that's that's suicide you
don't buy a house with someone you're
not married to ever so wow what a mess